good afternoon thanks for coming we're
going to start with the test we're going
to start
about perception and we want to know if
you can perceive a state change and the
state change is going to be conveyed to
you through music and I'm going to play
one of the clips that you created Chris
do you want to introduce it briefly
doing anything about well to introduce
it would be to give away what you're
right okay okay so we're just going to
listen to it there are so no
introduction it's going to take a minute
and I'm going to ask you to tell me
where the state changes in this sound
[Music]
okay where was this a change okay at 16
2750 okay and and this is a massive one
at the very end right you notice that
everything sort of hums along goes below
a little more there's a few changes in
there but there's one really massive one
at the very end now Chris for the reveal
what do I've been listening to so this
is this is a kind of a mash-up of
various data sets from ice cores in
Antarctica and there's deuterium kind of
humming along the lower fuzzier sound
and then the carbon dioxide is the
higher more whistling thing about an
occupier and your multiple state changes
those are actually the interglacial
periods along 800,000 years of the data
record in this thing d tyrion because
it's a proxy for temperature and gives
us you know good good trace of something
that by ear and by I you can see very
correlated you know with the carbon
dioxide levels so thank you so they feel
a lot older after listening to this is
because you just listen to 800,000 years
worth of data compressed into one minute
and that's one of the fundamental
challenges of climate change is that
temporarily it is a very complex thing
to perceive in terms of cause and effect
because we're used to perceiving causes
and effects within a range of maybe a
minute an hour a week but after that our
cause and effect correlations serve
break down because we can't remember
what happened a week ago and so clearly
unless it's really traumatic and but
here we're dealing with effects that
that we have to understand in the
context of 800,000 dr so way beyond the
experience of a lifetime and that's a
huge challenge so let's let's deal with
these challenges a little bit and look
at what kinds of methods we might have
to to understand climate change better
what i did as an artist is I actually
chose to travel to a ground zero of
climate
change and that ground zero is a barrow
alaska and just to introduce barrow
alaska i'm going to show this picture is
what i saw when i got off the airplane
barrow alaska the northernmost point of
the United States and I expected to see
not penguins because that's Antarctica
but I expected to see you know beautiful
icebergs and maybe a few Eider ducks
flying by and what I actually ended up
seeing was a an ice field this is Arctic
ice this is in June it's very cold it's
like freezing of course and I expect it
to be much more pristine but it really
wasn't it was dirty it was full of trash
it was it was melting it was not looking
as pristine as I thought it would was
and yet it was full of a very profound
mood of a certain kind of realism that I
that I was very impressed with so I'm
going to show a few travel pictures and
as I do I'm going to pass around two
artifacts that I want to share with you
this is a piece of baleen from whale
from a bowhead whale that is been carved
by local Native American artists into a
decorative item with three polar bears
and some melting ice around us and my
pass that one around and another
important thing about Barrow is that
there's a huge scientific research a
reserve that is managed by the people of
Barrow by the the and this for the
benefit of scientists and it is
separated by these markers they've been
replaced i was able to take this one
along it's separated by these markers
from the Native American hunting grounds
which is very important because you
don't want to get science and hunting
mixed up and so so these I'm going to
pass this around if you actually want to
smell it it still smells like the tundra
it smells like this pd kind of tundra so
you can pass that around as well that's
just so we have tangible evidence here
that we actually saw this place and
there's another third component which
I'm going to pass around and then we
have everything set up and the third
component is created by Christine Jang
and Aquila Raja who's right here and
they are going to show a
our implementation of several pictures
from the end from the Arctic trip and
you can put this on your headset and
explore it there's a button on the side
you can tap the button to get from one
sphere to another sphere and I'm very
interested in seeing how you enjoy this
experience and it so let's go on onwards
here and the first point I want to make
is that climate change is not a thing
climate change as bruno latour
philosopher described thing is something
that we all agree on thing is something
we can pin down and here we have a
literal example of a dragonfly being
pinned down to explain this concept is
from the Essex Museum of entomology in
berkeley and and so once something is
pinned down we can serve all agree to
what it is and then it becomes a thing
but climate change is much larger than
us and it certainly doesn't want to be
pinned down so therefore we can't quite
agree on it and it doesn't become a
thing it's it's something else and you
could say that it's kind of like like
this is very dark thought but it's kind
of like death itself death when it
doesn't happen it doesn't exist and when
it does happen we don't exist and
climate change is the same way when it
doesn't happen we really don't care much
about it we don't feel it but when it
does happen then our existence is put
into jeopardy so so it's not a thing
it's something else and it's something
that's very hard to communicate and to
mediate and let us explore what else we
can do with it so just looking at Barrow
this is the top of the world as the as a
monument that has been in it's a it's in
not in great shape it's been
weather-beaten but it's used to say Todd
welcome to the top of the world the
northernmost point of the United States
so I'm talking here about US territory
and what's happening in the US territory
up here is that the soil is melting away
the permafrost is no longer frozen and
its melting away fairly rapidly much
more rapidly than scientists expected
and one of the reasons I went up there
is to actually experience this because
reading about it is one thing but
walking on soft permafrost is a whole
different experience and we'll get into
that more more rapid
but the person that guided me through
this is a Margaret torn and she's a
professor of climate science and soil
science at lb Lawrence Berkeley National
Labs and Chris's daughter or a chief who
happened to be working with Margaret or
so we'll we'll meet all these people as
we go along here so when you freeze
something for 3,000 years that means the
plant matter contained in the soil is is
a solid frozen solid that means microbes
can get to it and it just sits there and
microbes have nothing to eat so there is
no production of there is no production
of methane and there's no production of
carbon dioxide however this has recently
changed very dramatically in that same
fashion that we heard when the sound
went up at the very end of the sample so
so you have to imagine permafrost is as
a massive layer of soil that has not
been decomp over then plant matter has
not been decomposed for 3,000 years and
now because it's melting microbes are
having a field day eating tons of
surplus material and are really
productive and they're releasing a
carbon dioxide and methane like they've
never done before in the summer season
and this is what it looks like so this
is a single methane bubble in Barrow
Alaska in June 2016 so there's there's a
the tundra is a lot of wetland and it's
a very marshy very swampy but there's
grass that comes out and every blade of
grass has bubbles percolating around it
and these are either co2 or methane
bubbles and they have a very significant
impact on the global warming because
they're an additional production of
greenhouse gases that is accelerating
dramatically and exponentially but to
illustrate the problem we're really not
worried about this one bubble what we're
worried about is this
and I'm not sure if this I think this
has no sound at all so we can talk over
it here we have a windproof drone
there's a lot of wind up there 30 miles
per hour can we lower the lights a
little bit so we can get the image more
clearly lens Thank You Lance um yes so
here we're flying a drone there's a
professional pilot controlling it
actually it's an algorithm that he
programmed but still and we're flying
towards in in this you got the marker
that you pass on who has the marker you
have it does it smell like Chandra you
get it the tundra smell a little bit
yeah okay well within that research area
marked by that marker you can fly drones
and do research and here's a bunch of
installations on the left you see a tram
that goes back and forth and samples
soil and air quality throughout the seat
throughout the warmer season and looks
at how much snow melts and things like
how fast snow melts and things like that
and then in the middle there what we're
flying towards is a is a Eddie flux
station that measures the flow of gases
from the air into the soil and from the
soil into the air there's a research
project national research project funded
by the Department of Energy which is
very interested in global climate change
but apparently in the next
administration this is going to change
so it's an interesting topic all these
Eddie flogged stations might be defunded
soon if we're not careful anyways we're
flying right up to this drone this uh
this sensor here and I hope we're not
going to run into it careful careful now
careful now ok close call and and we're
going to go up 400 feet here and this is
just to illustrate what the tundra look
it looks like it so it's not a single
blade of grass we're talking about we're
talking about a massive emanation of
gases across a huge huge area what you
see is the strange melting patterns
they're called well there's many many
terms for them with the melting panels
produce polygons and the polygons have
ice wedges around them that keep the
polygons they contract and expand and
these polygons shapes produce and the
contractions expansions produce these
strange polygon shapes
and they're so you sometimes have a soft
melted poor part right next to a hard
part and actually there's ever
particularly interesting formation
called the Iceland's still going on and
so sometimes you have soil that is
melted and on top and soil that is
melting the bottom and you have a big
piece of ice in the middle and so
there's really complex it really complex
shapes that emerge this looks like a
different planet doesn't it is so so
amazingly foreign and you see some
pieces of ice that are underwater so
because the the ice is not floating up
it's it's tied to the ground and it's
there's water above the ice and water
below the ice and then the ice lenses
sit in there in these ponds we keep
going now we're getting a lot of wind up
here so if you heard the audio to be
like and cuz I because there's nothing
stopping the wind this is called the
north slope and as well as far as the
eye can see there is nothing but Tundra
these little trails or trails that
people walk on to get to their research
installations because you can't drive
there because it would disrupt the
scientific nature of the preserve
sometimes people do drive and they leave
these tracks behind and the tracks are
there for hundreds of years they don't
they don't go away because then there's
nothing that changes them well and then
here's the view of the horizon and as
you can see this the flatland does not
end until we run out of horizon so how
much tundra is there how much permafrost
is melting right now
and here we're looking due north right
now this is straight to the North Pole
North Pole is about a thousand miles
away from here here the propeller of the
drone okay
so that's the full 360 and there's not a
town not a mountain nothing inside okay
and so the question was how much
permafrost land is there 8.8 million
square miles so this is a gigantic
process that is beginning and I don't
think anybody knows how to stop it so it
is very very very scary but we are
observing it very closely and one of the
reasons why we know so much about this
region is because Noah has been up in
Barrow for for some since 1971 and
they've been studying co2 up there and
temperature and so the very last piece
of Chris's music that you heard before
is produced by this this kind of data
collection up here where you are where
we could see the correlation between co2
and temperature changed since 1970s
called the Keeling curve after the
scientists who discovered it and the air
quality gets studied here in this in
this observatory and it's quite
beautiful because it's also
spontaneously built everything is kind
of kind of improvised so I'm going to go
over here we introduce you to lieutenant
Diane Perry who sits up there on this
tower and you have to climb up on this
thing every day to maintain it imagine
doing that in high winds and so forth
and there's no rails nothing you just
have to sort of get up there safely and
get back down again and this is one of
the images that's in the VR device in
the who has to be our device right now
it's over there and I want to mention to
you that if you tap on the side you get
from one bubble to the other and we're
very proud of this this is our media
innovation that actually works so so so
so is it the challenge is how do you get
from one VR picture to another because
they're always so enclosed and there's
no page to turn really right and so so
we thought that maybe if we just rise
through the bubbles we get an
experience of transitioning from one
space to another and that actually works
and so so you can try that just by
tapping on the side is that correct is
out there Craig construction okay good
thank you all right let's explore this
region a little bit further the Keeling
curve 1971 the average was at 331 parts
per million and today and well in that
that at that time the ground was frozen
solid i'm going to show you something
very unique here which is the the inside
of an ice cellar so if you have
permafrost and you need to hold on to
food you can simply dig into the ground
and you have a deep freezer and it stays
rock-solid frozen for the entire year
and and so you can see the ice crystals
on the side of the wall you see the
ladder goes down the ladder is very very
slippery because it's covered with blood
from people carrying meet up and down
and it's a little hairy that way but you
see a single light illuminates the whole
thing and if we come around here if we
look below a little bit we can see
pieces of whale meat being stored on the
soil and you see me trying to take
pictures without stepping on the whale
mean which we have been very rude I was
told and that's the cave that's what it
looks like and this is really quite
amazing it's it's touched the world it's
totally cold and then here's a hatch and
of course they were joking we're going
to close the hatch and let you feel what
a nice seller is really like but I did
get out I guess and today the Keeling
curve indicates that we're at 400 7.5 8
parts per million on average in December
of 2015 which is far more and which
really produces all these dramatic
effects so let's continue on the trail
of the whale meat here and look how they
will this is the house on top of the ice
cellar and this is in Barrow a very
elegant home because it has a big ice
cellar that's clean and because it's
well insulated this is about an eight
hundred thousand dollar home in
in Barrow and here are members of the
edwardson clan and they're all checking
out the loading of the of the whale meat
are preparing for a celebration where
they're going to share this will meet
with the whole community and it gets put
in the truck and here's the hotel not
the hotel I stayed in the Arctic hotel
is one of the two hotels there and so
the whale meat goes off and it gets
shared in a family dinner here again at
the edwardson home and so the big chunks
of Wilma gets sliced into these little
bits and these little bits are very true
and you can eat them they have a very
high protein they're extremely
nourishing a lot of fat too and you can
what they do is they preserve it by
putting it into the the blood of way
wale blood and somehow there's a
fermentation process in the whale blood
and then whale meat comes together and
it becomes softer and more more easy to
chew as is the traditional olu knife
that they use to cut the meat into
little bits and going on here these
houses are very much clan houses and
this is a bit of a funny picture as
loading here it has a has a after the
lunch that we had there with the whale
meat we had a gentleman guarding the
house and I think that this this
situation here where he's looking out of
the house and he's checking out what's
going on there's some people out there
guarding the house as well just looking
out and seeing what's happening and the
juxtaposition of the sewing machine and
the marine shotgun is a very descriptive
of the Native American lifestyle it's a
it's a subsistence lifestyle in this
case where we're sewing is important to
keep you know to build your boats with
seal skin and so forth into a to make
your clothes and to fix things because
you're very far away there's no roads
that lead to Barrow you're completely
isolated and then of course the daily
practice of hunting which is what we're
a large part of the diet comes from I
think up to ninety percent of the diet
comes from hunting
and then on the back yard here this view
here and there's a different kind of
looking out that the scientists produce
and it's even more contained this is the
inside of the lab where the the where we
saw the tower earlier the the NOAA
Observatory where the gas samples come
in and they get analyzed and stored and
it's the very heart of it where where
the the tubes bring the gas to the
sensor this this building's been around
for a very look for a very long time CC
generations of scientific equipment
piled on top of each other look around
here here only teflon pipes reference
gas containers to calibrate the
equipment and so so this brings us to
this observation that that climate
change is really not something that can
be communicated in a simple way and when
what I'm mostly concerned with right now
is how many people seem to think climate
change is not a problem at all and some
people think it is a problem and some
people think of it make a lot of
measurements and make a lot of write a
lot of papers about it and articulated
with a lot of detail but still we're not
really communicating about the problem
and so so the metaphor of comparing
climate change to death works here as
well because everybody has a specific
and individual idea of what death is
like and we respect that about each
other in most most cases and say oh
that's how you imagined it that's how I
imagined because we know that none of us
have a complete understanding of what
that means and so so my reframing of
climate change conceptually would be to
say that we admit that we have no idea
what's really going on entirely that all
our renderings are incomplete and if all
our renderings of this idea all our
mediations around this idea are
incomplete then we can start listening
to other people's incomplete notions of
climate change and consider them as such
and the hope is that if we put it all
together we get a clearer picture but
it's still incomplete but definitely we
can't afford to discard any of the
responses and so one of the mysteries
for me in Barrow was that all of the
native ameri
I spoke to where Trump voters and they
had posters for Trump on their on their
houses and I actually had this strange
experience where I was taking pictures
of their houses and I looked at the
pictures later on and they saw the Trump
poster in one corner of an image and
then I took another picture and I saw
the trunk coaster and post in another
corner of the image but I could not get
myself to take a picture of that poster
because it didn't mesh with my idea of
what Native Americans should think about
climate change and I so it was my bias
that prevented me from actually seeing
what's going on and I thought there was
a fascinating failure and and in a way
an inspiration for all this utter work
and for taking a closer look at what we
don't pay attention to and so in order
to understand climate change we really
need a medium that gets us to look at
what we don't want to see and and the
situation in Barrow is it will see more
pictures is that the soil is literally
washing away from under the feet of the
of the of the inhabitants and it's a
tremendous challenge so one way to pay
attention leads to another sonification
and I'm going to play this but you want
to say something about it beforehand
right okay yet why did I so my daughter
always been going up there for three or
four years she works for Lawrence
Berkeley Lab and is a field biologist
she is running a number of experiments
which are you know basically gathering
data you know very very kind of hands-on
with the permafrost you can imagine that
so you saw that tram from the drone shot
it was a kind of long straight line and
i just called ori about an hour ago and
said how long is that tram I've never
been up there this is about 65 meters so
that gives you a sense of how long that
extent is and the very first summer she
went up there she sent me back some data
that she said hey here's some more
fodder for your crazy sonification
experiments see what you'd want to do
with this and you'll hear it in a sec
it's it's kind of revealing I just got
another sort of explanation from her to
refresh my memory of what that data
is well it's that location exactly where
the tram is and she spent an afternoon
which became the first of three summers
worth of afternoons where she hauls a
bunch of equipment out there and she's
measuring the release of these trace
gases from the permafrost right so the
way you do that this is this is the
methodology the experiment this very
particular experiment that she's
involved with its it's you know it's
high summer the plants or
photosynthesizing like crazy so they're
giving off these gases as well as the
permafrost which is you know implicated
in releasing it as well so how do you
distinguish from permafrost versus the
you know the plants that are on the
surface and the way you do it in her
method is chambers I think we had a shot
of the Chamber's I can't remember and
the VR version does it's off the
chambers with gas coming out and the
animation so if you get to that you know
what it is so so she she packs these
things out to the to the site and she
has a opaque chamber and a transparent
chamber that she puts down over the over
the ground and there's a gas analyzer
inside that's measuring methane and
carbon dioxide so the difference between
the one that's open and the one that's
opaque gives you the difference between
day and night and plants which are alive
and photosynthesizing actually respond
to lighten that way obviously whereas
the permafrost itself is not light
sensitive and so looking at say five
minutes of readings from the open
chamber the light the you know the one
that's open till I day one yeah gives
you a particular rising slope of the
gases being chapt trapped in that
chamber then you do the same thing with
the black one and you get a very
different slope the difference in slopes
indicates the contribution from the
permafrost it's a way of eliminating the
contribution from the plants if that
makes sense hopefully so
what you're going to hear is actually
just a kind of tune with a rhythm to it
where her whole afternoon is compressed
into I don't know how long this last
couple minutes 33 minutes and the rhythm
is like chamber dark chamber pack up
your gear move three yards light chamber
dark chamber and what you're going to
hear is the actual rise of the the co2
and the methane as separate musical
voices from each of those chambers so if
I took a long time explaining that
compare that to what you're going to
hear because you're going to hear that
rhythm right off the bat you're going to
hear the variation the correlations
right off the bat and that's that's sort
of one of the fun things we're exploring
right now with a company and graphical
data with sound data and using our kind
of musical percepts to pick up on some
of the patterns so so just to build a
little bit the research here that's
being sana fide is a process of taking a
cycle that are normally lasts 24 hours
the day/night cycle and bringing that
down to a six hours experiment of a
person walking through and checking
various various kinds of callers they
call them I think yeah and then taking
that experience and pressing it
compressing it down to three minutes and
so so that's important aspect of climate
communications
[Music]
so it's the next set light dark
she explained that she's going from the
more liquid to the more dry end of that
so it does change is kind of an
ingredient
[Music]
yeah and for for my own purposes this is
a music I've never heard before and you
know is just you know a sound phenomenon
it's kind of intriguing it has a rhythm
to it has a lot of built-in character
but it has this other message which
which I think Greg will continue with
now so you get that you get the idea and
oh yeah that's good it keeps going and
these are online i can i can certainly
provide your ills for them
[Music]
anyway proud parent she's just really
methodical I'll tell you you know all
right so let's look what that looks like
so yeah so Native American inupiats High
School in Barrow has an archaeology lab
because the archaeologist is underfunded
and figured that if the high school
students can help her identify various
samples and sort them she'll get more
coverage what's happening is that a lot
of archaeological sites are simply
washing into the sea because of the
permafrost melting so you find maybe
3,000 years of human occupation and the
archaeological record of that human
occupation being washed into the sea on
a daily basis and this archaeologist is
literally running around with buckets at
the seashore picking up bones and and I
believe this here is a the bone of a
petrified bone of a dinosaur is really
really old and but there's other ones
that are more reasons of and artifact
human artifacts and other the other
elements that are more recent while
while at the same time the scientist is
trying to capture gas that's coming out
of the ground that's actually been
carbon dated to be 3,000 years old so so
the the plant matter that's being
processed and metabolized by the
bacteria by the microbes here that meant
plan matters these houses year old so
the gas here has a signature of a
three-thousand-year-old creature and is
a different way of handling that and
then yeah so the archaeological sites
that are being washed into the sea they
can barely barely just collect it all
and put it in bags and rapidly
classified by where it came from but
there's no time to to study it there's
only time to just collect some of it and
of course labeling is very important and
here we have the beginning of what
alatorre bruno latour calls are
circulating reference so so the
scientists is actually in the field
measuring something real and then that
measurement gets written down the things
get labeled and
as we go through the circulating
reference the situation becomes more and
more abstract and and it is that
increasing abstraction that is both a
necessary in order to put our arms
around a wider range of knowledge than
we can perceive directly but also it
removes us from the subject and when I
talk to Native Americans over this
process and I said something to the
effect that I'm admiring how how well
they they manage to live off the land
and and they laughed them in said we
don't live off the land look at this
land there's nothing here not even a
tree comes forth but yet the land brings
us forth the land is much larger than us
we are not we're not thinking of the
land as a subject we're thinking of
ourselves as the subject of the land and
that's a fundamentally different way of
looking at environment and planet than
than we do and and in in this labeling
we turn something into a subject we say
okay this gas was recorded that it's I
collected at site 3a and we're now going
to analyze it and we're making it into a
thing making the Arctic into a thing
also happens at the scale of oil of
course in in Barrow there was a oil
exploration for a while but the results
were inconclusive and so the oil
drilling probes became monuments instant
monuments in the downtown square and
this is the big shopping center there
the value center and and that's the
monument right in front of it here's a
picture of science tools being the
syringes being discarded it kind of
looks like a flower and I think is
beautiful now another tool to manipulate
and interact with the environment the
harpoon is a stone harpoon this is from
pre this is one of the things that's
found in the archaeological sites that
can't be studied properly just collected
right now because there's too much of it
falling apart this is what this a
harpoon tip apparently that was made out
of stone here's the tourist attraction
that also was made by by the Inupiat to
to entertain tourists and the ideas that
tourists all
want to get into boats and into these
seal boats and go go rolling around in
the Arctic but apparent the kayaks
apparently that's not a good idea
because it's very dangerous and so they
made this photo up where you can put
your head through a panel and we that
looks like so it looks like you're
sitting in one of these seal boats and
sealskin boats and right behind it is
the actual Arctic and so that's one way
of looking at the situation and then the
scientific way of looking at the
situation can produce this kind of shape
here there are satellites and those
satellites maintain communications with
with this has a lot to do with military
installations as well maintain
communications with home base stations
and it's exactly the opposite the
sensory device needs to be contained and
packaged and protected from the elements
instead of being being connected to the
elements since the direct opposite of
the previous one there's whale bones all
around town because it's the sharing and
the collecting and sharing of whale meat
is very important part of the community
and so they get exhibited there as
trophies and they're really quite huge
and quite beautiful a different kind of
dome there's no satellite in this one
the whale map from 1880 indicates where
good whaling grounds are and of course
between the period of 1830 and 1880
there was a lot of whaling up in this
area that brought a lot of white people
into the into contact with the Inupiat
and there was a lot of intermarriage and
that's why many Inupiat have western
names such as Edwardson or Nelson or so
and the whole period of history was
extremely exploitative and reduced the
population of Wales dramatically the
Inupiat hunt 15 whales a year and that
seems to be in balance with the
population and 15 to 20 maybe whales in
a year and then that seems to work and
they hunt them with this kind of thing a
sealskin boat as a picture of one that
was recently put on the beach by members
of the
brower family and so we have their flag
there which is a cargo culture example
it's a their flags are taken from the
sailing alphabet from the sales from the
from the from the flag alphabet that
sailors used to use in the in the
whaling period and this boat here you
can see it's a made of steel skin
wrapped around wood and it's not much
maybe seats five people or so and it's
much smaller than the whale that they're
trying to hunt with it this is an inside
look at the whaleboat this kind of
whaling boat and you think they're
Christian because they put a little
cross there but by the relationship
between Christianity and Native American
beliefs is very complex still today the
pastors who are there are active there
tell the Inupiat that their traditional
ways are devil worship and that they
have to you know apologize and ferb pray
for forgiveness for their sins when they
sing up to the traditional song when I
heard this I was like is this 2016 is
this the United States this is so
possible absolutely yes it's a very
complex cargo culture where ideas get
exchanged and sometimes in very
unfortunate ways and so that burden of
traditional law knowledge being labeled
as devil worship is still alive and well
in this community it's very troubling
the beautiful sight so also the boat
itself is used to be built out of whale
bones but now it's being built out of
wood that the driftwood mostly or wood
from shipping pallets that's that comes
there because there's no wood up in this
area at all here's a sad picture of a
graveyard in Barrow so you see the the
ocean is right that white line back
there that's the ice in the horizon and
the ocean is making incursions into the
land and the land is melting away and
and this is a graveyard that's been
there for a hundred years and it's just
washing into the sea and you know that's
that's their daily picture that's what
you wake up to in the morning when you
go for a walk mining is equally
challenging there's a lot of gravel
that's being mined there because gravel
is very important for the oil industry
to build platforms on the perimeter
there you can build houses own and so
gravel is a huge resources of United
States federal mining location 444
gravel but the whole mining operation
has itself begun to sink into the ground
because because of permafrost melting
issues and so it's not a very active
side anymore here's our field scientists
trying to collect all this and feeling
very good after a three-mile hike the
daily hike to just go collect some
samples this is Ari chafe and she's
going up there soon again right so this
continues oh yeah yeah it's a lot of
work to capture so much as possible here
we're going to take another look at the
edwardson clan here's the edwardson clan
flag which is taken from the N from the
sailing alphabet sorry I be sailing
alphabet B and no no no it's N I should
know it's and it's not for Edwards and
it's for Nelson which was a previous the
previous captain's last name but it
stays in the clan the name changes
sometimes here is the court in a very
interesting contradiction when the
Native Americans try to figure out how
to deal with land ownership and they
realized that there was oil and that the
United States government was interested
in taking over the oil-bearing parts of
the land and nationalizing the the lands
they had a choice they had a choice they
could either fight the land take over
the eminent domain land takeovers and
thereby abandoned their traditional ways
which are very peace oriented and very
consensus oriented they could either
fight and contradict their traditions or
they could not fight and stay with their
traditional Native American Inupiat way
of dealing with challenges by being very
accommodating and lose the land as a
result and so that contradiction was not
leading to any good results but until
some somebody a native american name d
talk and his friends had an idea to
create a do Pekovic in New p
corporation and the corporation could
fight for the land on behalf of the
Native Americans so it was like a a
device they could hold up in order to
perform in a way they didn't want to
perform themselves but on their behalf
so it was a very interesting path out of
a contradiction and so this will pick it
up a cubic corporation is very important
runs almost everything in the town and
so when you rent a car you rented from
lupe from you UIC and when you rent a
hotel room you hit rented from UIC as
well and there most of their business
however is in government services in
maintaining military bases around the
world and they got those contracts
through through through through
relationship with the senator Alaska
Senator so this is a corporate Lulu you
don't want to mess with that this is the
UICC oh the guy was holding the flag
earlier here is in his corporate office
so the performance of holding the flag
and the performance of sitting in the
corporate office are very different you
see different aspects of the man Anthony
here and his lands vice president Lars
Nelson and last few images here we have
a abandoned Quonset science lab and it
says on it blocked from the inside and
when I saw that sign I realized wait a
minute that's exactly the challenge
we're trying to deal with that many of
the things we ought to perceive we can
perceive not because they're not there
but because our own perceptual apparatus
is too limited were blocked from the
inside from allowing certain insights to
become become become become relevant for
us and so I was blocked from the inside
because I couldn't see the the Trump
sign that was hanging on the door there
for everybody to see and maybe some
other people are blocked from the inside
in the sense that they they they don't
have a choice but to live on the land
that is changing so much and to to
respond to the changes in whichever way
they can but to move for Native
Americans in this case is not an option
and so what they're thinking of is
building harbors
that are floating floating harbors that
allow for the northwestern passage for
shapes to come through Barrow again or
not again but for the first time and so
they have great plans of building
basically floating Native American
islands that are essentially on
artificial land and and maybe that's
going to work I hope it will but all of
these things we can only wrap our minds
around if we if we are able to consider
the problem beyond what is blocking us
inside and beyond the immediate temporal
timeframe temporal framework so here's a
beautiful still of a flower growing up I
thought we have to put in one positive
image after all these dark images
amazing vegetation growing in the tundra
it's one of those softest most beautiful
landscapes I've ever walked in and that
feeling of walking is almost like
walking on a mattress but the mattress
is 8.8 million square miles and you can
just keep going on and you can just lie
down and it smells great and feels great
but it is definitely changing so we're
going to close our last element here is
a brief video I wonder should we show it
or should we take some questions how
we're doing with time we have like ten
minutes left right okay so this one's
six minutes i'm going to show three
minutes because i would like to hear if
there's any questions right sound good
so i'm going to show a little bit of
this this is a project that's inspired
by the visit to alaska and it's a
collaboration with chris chief again
Chris shave composed music that's based
on a sample of so first of all do you
know that the Sun has a day the day as
in it rotates around its own axis every
27 days the Sun rotates around its own
axis as interesting and so what we did
is we took one of the readings of
radiation from the Sun over a cycle of
27 days because the radiation changes
depending on which side of the Sun is
facing us and how many some flares there
are and the reading we were looking at
was from I think was from June 1st 2 jun
27th is that right Chris and at the data
looks something like this this was the
radio flux intensity data
then in the composition you're about to
hear we took this data and made this
data be the speed of the music okay so
the speed changes is slow fast slow very
fast slow but then we the melody came
from a three-fold repetition of this
same data so you hear the same data
three times but at different speeds
which makes it feel very different and
at the same time on the video you have
the revolution of the Sun around its own
axis of 121 times over the past nine
years so you're going to experience
three time scales at the same time and
let's see what this looks like it's the
first time we show this anywhere so oh
well this was performed live in Michigan
as a carillon concerts you're going to
hear a lot of bells and we're don't have
time for this right now but there's an
app where you can play along so you
could play the bells along with the
performance and that's what you hear
you're here the carol knows playing but
you can also hear some people with cell
phones playing along and this playing a
long effect is a another time frame
because not everybody hits the key at
the right time
[Music]
you
there that was the first three minutes
and it sometimes almost little cat
cacophonous the whole thing is like what
the heck is going on what annoys is this
but at the same time there's these
really beautiful structures of slowing
down and accelerating that I here in the
music and I really enjoy that and
there's another effect that you pointed
out Chris which is that if we look at
the Sun like this it becomes kind of
like a ball that we can almost imagine
holding in our hand and then the Sun
becomes kind of a thing which is the
topic we started with but the thing is
still alive it's not pinned to death and
if we can find this balance between
holding something as a thing but at the
same time keeping it alive so then it
exists and then we can really perceive
what it's all about and is that that
subtle balance between objectification
and compassion and really just living
with it that that I think would be the
proper framework for mediation around
climate change thank you very much
[Applause]
alright so let's take a few questions
maybe and yes there is any living things
I plants or animals that were demons and
well there is a lot of migration of
species about a hundred miles north that
we were observing and and there's
various measures maybe you would know
more simple about exactly what the rates
are but they're Bahrain the the species
migrate about 100 miles north on a scale
of about 10 years species also change
their body parts so there's a collection
of bees bumblebees no honey bees that
change this if you look at them from
1872 today you can see in the last 40
years that's the size of their tongue
change to accommodate for a broader
feeding pattern it's fascinating so
within a cycle of 40 years the body
parts literally changed their size in
animals
but what's really creepy is that in that
Tundra frozen are viruses that we
haven't seen in 3,000 years and they're
coming out so so there's anthrax there's
botulism and there's multiple viruses
that have never been seen before and
it's not clear what they do and so we we
may have all sorts of surprises there so
far none of them have affected humans
but on that's that's definitely a
possibility so yes it's best to keeps
frozen things frozen maybe huh yes any
other questions I don't know if you're
familiar with Nick's obvious status on
occasion he does he make like turn data
for a single classical music yes and I'm
curious why like why you guys chose to
use the sounds that you did and the
instruments that you did that's a great
question we use the bells because the
bells are a traditional alarm and sort
of bringing people together kind of
sound and also because they are very
interesting overtones where they
resonate with each other in complex ways
and if you strike a bell just once it
produces many overtones but Chris you're
the expert on this well sometimes want
to get involved with data sets I like to
get a just a sound quality that suggests
what the data came from I first go at
this I score work it's it's actually in
conjunction with some geophysicists up
in University of British Columbia and
one of them heard this first attempt
said wow it's down it starts sounding
like a boiling tea pot at the end is a
great you know sometimes just looking
for suggestive coupling between things I
work a lot with EEG and brain waves and
I use the human voice for that because
it's human data in it yes this is a
growing feeling a lot of people are
working with it right now so we're very
excited about it any other questions
yeah
[Music]
last one yeah they know that our Trump
is a funny thing I really don't know
much about this I wouldn't want to speak
for them but when I worked in the
Maldives as a as an artist to represent
the Maldives in the Venice Biennale
there were some Mel deviants who were
climate change deniers even as the water
was literally coming over the sidewalk
and they and and the logic of that is
that wouldn't you rather it weren't the
case in that situation wouldn't you
rather wish that that wasn't what was
happening and there's a powerful thought
in place there that is if we accepted we
make it even more real but if we deny it
we somehow distance ourselves from it
and the physical reality is not the same
as the mental reality and the question
is what produces a more actionable
outcome for us if we constantly think oh
it's melting away there's nothing left
to do but to run away then there's not
much we can't that putting doesn't put
an actionable k situation but if we
think I got to go home to seal and I
gotta go get my get out there somehow
and figure out how to do that the
different thoughts kick in we're
thinking about climate change may not be
the most effective thought on the other
hand they do describe very subtly and
more subtly than most anyone I've ever
spoken to how the nature how the
environment changes they can tell you
exactly how what the temperature was on
this day a year ago and where there was
warmer or colder I couldn't tell you
what the temperature was on December or
ninth the 2015 but a Native American in
in in in Barrow would be able to
describe this and say yeah and the
hunting was good over there and now it's
good over here so they're very much in
tune with the changes all the while not
not accepting maybe the fundamental
considerations of climate change because
it's too abstract but it's more concrete
the knowledge right yeah good one more
good one more question the very notion
of starting from data
of that idea of starting from data to
produce me of address energy that's a
great question absolutely we do we think
that the one medium is definitely not
enough and we all peace of data has a
bias and has a limitation and and
sometimes just looking at the data makes
you not look outside and look at what's
happening right in front of you so
there's many many other pictures that
describe that and many many limitations
and I think the the sauna fication
actually makes the data a little bit
less abstract and a little bit less
absolute because it becomes more
associated and maybe it actually opens
up a survey loose your coupling between
inside and data and not so much a a
tunnel version of looking at the data
nothing else I think it's very important
that we that we collect all these things
and put them together all these
influences and put them together great
great to talk more explain to me the
difficulty in making this moving images
that the show for six minutes in the Sun
movie that stitching together data is
seems to be a theme that we're
encountering a lot and it's a subject
not a problem right that's great let's
let's end and then wrap it up so so
these pictures were taken over a period
of ten years and in that time the jpeg
standard changed multiple times and so
we have pictures that are not going to
go into the same video editor the same
way so we first have to and I'm like oh
why didn't Massa figure this out come on
people and then I was thinking know the
trouble of stitching this stuff together
is is is producing exactly is living
with that question of what does the data
actually mean and and is it just a
representation or is it a replacement
for the real thing and when you realize
how fractured the data record is and
struggle with that you very much live
the experience of its of its fragility
and of its limitations and the same
thing with your 800,000 years right that
ice core sample was collected by
multiple scientists in different ways
and so putting it all together is very
hard okay what one more thing did you
all get the experience the VR experience
is it going around can you give can you
have some feedback to to Christine and
about how it worked how was the
experience good applause boo Falls okay
so maybe that's you know VR is also
something that takes our very perceptual
apparatus out of the world inception and
hides our perceptions from others and so
it's a strange thing to go in there and
look at data that way but maybe the
immersion produce opens something else
so all these things need to be explored
okay thank you very much